okay the game should begin any second
whoa
and they've started all right el ereza
sorry sorry alireza i can't play any
longer
but the game has just begun and here we
go
here we go um let's sit back let's watch
let's cheer him on i'm nervous
good luck to charlie let the better
player win
i don't know if ludwig knows the game
has started
i don't know if charlie if ludwig knows
the game is sorry maybe ludwig just felt
they're both
very nervous i honestly think the game
is going to be they just got lucky with
afk
keeps their composure i don't think the
opening is going to decide the game but
what is ludwig doing
he is i mean this will probably have to
be restarted i don't think he knows the
game
get that game aborted okay
and he plays a scandinavian so that's
already an opening surprise
now we prepared for this against mr
beast
so okay queen to d6 so that's uh just a
line of the scandy
sammy the mc ludwig deviating
grandmaster hess
with the opening work this was
impossible to predict
this was impossible to predict we've
gone over the scandinavian
well there's a i think alireza knows i'm
watching charlie
i i okay but ali reza no i i already
knows that i'm watching charlie so
i i didn't make this a surprise
okay so charlie just needs to develop
his pieces
um knight f3 d4
and uh there is no particular way to
play this line this is a line of the
scandinavian
yep d4 there we go and see this is where
i'm i'm glad lovely play this because
this is where charlie's actual
knowledge is going to be tested thank
you for the prime
all right this isn't even like the
scandinavian i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is
oh man has with full do respect has done
that a bunch of times
okay so knight f3 excellent good good
good good
a6 yeah so ludwig is playing a
legitimate variation of the scandi
and uh charlie just needs to develop his
pieces just get your pieces out there's
there's nothing in particular that has
to be done here
thank you shaq steves for the tier one
yeah ludwig is moving fast charlie's got
to move though
yeah queen d6 is the third possible move
here
yeah don't go king e2 thank you cheeky
lw for the prime
he's i'm sure ludwig is still in prep
tv okay charlie just uh develop your
pieces here there's no
legitimate off the defense of this pawn
the issue is that after knight c6 that's
ludwig's idea
charlie might end up losing this pawn
but that's actually fine you can
sometimes sacrifice this font
especially and uh you can get a lot of
play in return for that pawn i told him
not to care about pawns
i don't care if charlie loses a pawn as
the
game is nine we decided by who loses a
pawn um so if he castles
ludwig is gonna go bishop g4 so i would
go h3 here and maybe bishop e3 which is
a defensive posture but not bad
he's he's already overthinking though he
just needs to develop his pieces i
honestly don't care about the d4 pawn
the game is not going to be decided by
an extra pawn
knight e2 very passive very passive by
charlie
and now bishop g4 i mean maybe he's
preparing bishop f4 that would be
interesting
but i don't like how passively he's
playing in the early going here opens
this up
yeah he could have also not defended the
pawn and and prepare to discover check
my only concern with charlie is that is
that he hasn't
done a lot of puzzles in the last couple
weeks and that is just
really hurting his tactical form
92 is fine i mean it's not a horrible
move but the problem is that ah and he
finds bishop g4
yeah a lot of gladuegas looked up this
line
and there was there's just no way that
we could have predicted this
okay
so bishop f4 good so ludwig can give a
check on before and win the bond but
that's very dangerous he could get his
queen trap there
you could get his queen trap there i
mean clearly they are both
now improvising they are both out of
preparation
they are both out of preparation
i mean ludwig has never played this
before i i have i had no way of knowing
that this was
that this is gonna happen
okay
so no but but it's again it's not about
pawns here it's about rapid development
okay so now they're both they're both
clearly out of theory i like the way
charlie is playing here
i believe in his fundamentals
he has an assault oh he has an alts i
didn't know that
okay whatever
okay this is looking looking fine for
charlie now as ludwig takes his time
here
queen b4 is is very very bad for black
because charlie but he needs to develop
he needs to realize that it's not about
pawns queen to d7 is
fine yeah
okay so now i would go c3 let him let
him take on f3 it's fine and then i
would prefer castling long and fire
charlie maybe
i think this might be a time to scramble
the way they're playing 95 here
leads to a good position for white too
taking here but my guess is charlie will
play c3
he does good professionally done
okay so ludwig can ruin his pawn
structure but giving up that bishop is
he's good he's also not bad for white
playing the same diagonal
yeah well if yeah so now ludwig is
probably going to castle that's
what robert i mean that's the logical
yep he does
yeah 95 would be an excellent move 95
would be an excellent move here trade
the knights
solid position i'm liking this this is a
good position out of the opening
and like i said the game will not be
decided by the opening
queen b3 is fine here too yeah
queen c2 i mean he needs to notice that
the queen in the rook queen c2 would be
a nice move
well i tried to hammer down time
management one swish and thing for the
prime
i mean they're both taking a long time
here
[Music]
i don't like castling though because
then you can take an f3 and ruin the
structure
although that's not the end of the world
obviously
95 is very logical
95 is very logical 95 takes takes
okay taking way too long here
yeah but queenside pawns is a very high
level he's not going to do that
he doesn't want a castle short h3 i
don't like that move at all
you shouldn't force the bishop to take
the knight because then ludwig can play
e5 there
which i don't think he's going to do
either
okay now okay but what it doesn't take
now they're both missing
the essence of the position oh that's a
horrible move no
now ludwig can take and take why would
you play h3 and then castle
um that's not great it's not the end of
the world either but it's not great
i think ludwig is going to see that
though
too too long g4 castle queenside
this will come down to yeah but ludwig
doesn't have any real follow-ups there
and
the question is will charlie see a move
like nike three threatening to win the
queen
not looking at it right now i don't
think ludwig is going to play it because
because uh ludder already moved his
bishop back there they are both
not managing their time on your 11 moves
they're already spent a bunch of a bunch
of clock here
i think they're both nervous as hell it
just seems that way
e5 is a very bad move e6 okay thank god
um now knight g3 by charlie get your
knight back
kick the bishop away
okay yeah they are both scared of each
other this is very clear from the moves
and one of them i mean hopefully charlie
just needs to snap out of it knight g3
here is a great move
knight g3 is a great move get the bishop
out get your knight better i've told him
a million times improve the position of
your pieces
this is i'm yeah terrified actually
95 is also fine it doesn't matter it's
it's
as long as he plays a decent move okay
now he's taking another minute on his
move
come on knight g3 charlie get the get
the bishop out
he's frozen again
no but i i mean it doesn't it doesn't
nothing matters other than time here
this is way too long
i don't know what to say b4 b3
a3 come on b4 push your pawns forward
oh my god blood finally seeing bishop f3
come on charlie go knight g3
i mean now bishop f3 is no longer
dangerous for white bishop f3 is no
longer dangerous is that no longer as
dangerous for white
g4
okay oh that's a pretty pretty weakening
move but i guess it's fine it's hard to
exploit this
uh i don't want to open this file though
okay it's hard to exploit this uh i'm
taking too long to find any other good
ones
um so i don't this i don't particularly
dislike this move actually a lot of i
can see thinking about a sacrifice
he is going to sacrifice hmm i like that
he sacrificed because
playing actually playing this line is
going to be very hard for ludwig take
the knight charlie
no but white is this is not a very sound
sacrifice take the knight
and move your knight to e5 come on 95
after take it just move your knight
white is in great shape then go f3 chase
the bishop
he's totally fine why is he thinking
no but but this is not not right i mean
he's just yeah there we go
ludwig is now playing fast he's
adjusting to the situation
move your knight
knight e5 well the problem is i'm not a
psychologist
um i i've tried my best to instill him
with some confidence but
he's got to press the button knight e5
is very simple knight h2 is also fine
but
um 92 bishop h3 is annoying so i would
play more aggressively
knight g3 walks into a pin now he's
going to kill him he
is he's going to just destroy himself
here over the clock
i can't believe this
no i mean he just buckles knight g3 okay
so
it's not a terrible move as long as he
can follow up with bishop e2
okay yeah bishop e2
okay telling somebody to work on their
nerves does it make them less nervous
um he's doing fine i mean he's four
minutes
ludwig with six i hope ludwig spends a
while on this move
he's my okay bishop dc no he's playing
fast
just take the bishop take it
take it and bishop e2 i mean simple
moves he finds these for breakfast
take the bishop simplify he's offering
him simplification
he's no but he knows he's up a piece
just take this should be two is better
here positioned
better give the queen a more active
square
yeah it's unreal three minutes now
he's retreating why he's up a piece he
is up a piece
i'm taking too long though i mean
retreating is not a horrible idea but
why
yeah he takes good but look at ludwig
playing fast i mean
you can just play fast and win on time
it should be too good
he's playing great i mean he's making
good moves but this clock situation is
killing me
at least something h5 and g5 man he's
but h5 you can just move the knight away
and ludwig doesn't have any attack
yeah h5 is a good move by ludwig
well no a lot of playing everything
right it's just time
honestly
he plays like he's 78 years old f6
okay that's a that does not do very much
just move the knight away
and and trade the trade the pieces
simplify the position
move the knight and simplify the
position just move the knight anywhere
go move
come on move move
move knight h2 anything knight d2
queen b3 just move the knight away trade
the bishops
okay queen b3 but now he's put himself
wide open for like h5
yeah i kind of i could sense this this
would happen
unfortunately
i mean 94 knight c5 is an interesting
idea
this does stop queen e5 and queen e5
wasn't really a threat
should just come over here and ludwig's
time management isn't great queen f4
would be a very strong move
by ludwig h5
yeah man knight a4 knight c5 is good
here
move you're still moving the night away
is good
yeah i'm gonna have to call him at the
break
good knight d4 knight c5 come on charlie
he might checkmate him here
queen f4 by ludwig he's not left himself
with a lot of time
to deal with these complications
but he's played a million blitz games
now ludwig might not not know how to
deal with this though
i'm getting [ __ ] up but queen f4 will
be insane from ludwig if he sees that
is he seeing is ludwig seeing queen f4
he's played a ton of blitz too like
three minutes is actually not
terrible for him
nope wow now if he plays queen d7
knight c5 wins the queen this is
dangerous for ludwig very
this is anybody's game
he's holding his queen but obvious
obviously he sees the queen
yeah also a low arm time now
oh my god he's gonna play it
knight c5 b6 he's going to play now he
sees it
okay yeah he's gonna play it
oh my god okay bacon incarnate thank you
wow
crazy but knight c5 charlie come on
thread and checkmate
96 yes he's got 96 there he's a lot of
i mean everybody's underrated as so i
don't understand
come on knight c5 knight c5 charlie
move knight c5 is such a simple move
yes yes yes yes yes very good very good
threatening we have our first checkmate
threat of the game
but ludwig is gonna have to defend
against that
he doesn't see the mate
he doesn't see the maid he'll see it
he doesn't see the mate oh my god please
take the knight please take the night
ludwig
please he saw it oh you just noticed
that okay
he sees it yes
no of course he will not blend in the
mate b6 96 though
is winning for white okay he
he sees the check
okay so ludwig might oh knight oh my god
he's on knight a5
are you kidding me
96 is a very interesting move
oh my god i can't believe you found
knight a5 that's just insane
queen b4 come on
96 here is interesting
yeah i can't believe he found them of
honestly i really want to get this at
some point
this game is really good yeah it is
queen d1 is fine too
queen d1 is fine here for white he needs
to move though
i'm honestly thinking i don't i mean
knight a5 is ridiculous
but that's not good because i do that um
i cannot believe he found that with
tempo i'm just going to do
simpler moves 96 is is fine just gotta
make a move queen a4
okay but now bishop f3 and black is
winning here with a rook left at the end
[Music]
okay maybe ludwig goes back to c6
hopefully
i mean finding the rook lift if he finds
a rook left he's earned the win
if he finds the rook lefties are in the
win this is not bad guys let's
let's not nobody nobody needs to we
don't need to be negative here this is a
very high level game actually
the only bad thing is the times ooh b6
is
risky but there's no mate there
but b6 is a good move actually it's an
incredibly high level move actually
this is an incredibly well played game
by both of them
oh my god he's i don't understand it
yeah it takes wow now charlie can take
bishop a6 is an idea but he won't no but
then it's made it's made
you'll see the rook lift probably
96 no but 96 gets mated he's got to take
that bishop
capitalize on it now
well the problem also with charlie is he
hasn't solved any puzzles he hasn't
solved puzzles and that's gonna kill him
unfortunately yes but he takes good
so is ludwig gonna is ludwig gonna take
that's the question
i mean 17 1800 level here from ludwig
does ludwig c
taken ludwig can't can draw but
i've tried to make him do puzzles yes
but charlie's a grown man
he can decide what to do with his time
that was my [ __ ] time [ __ ]
b6 that's a okay charlie can move his
bishop now keep his king protected
he rushed it but not bad i mean ludwig
will have to see the rook lift and
charlie might have to slide his queen
back to d1
still not bad i'm not i'm not unhappy
with that move it doesn't lose
he doesn't lose if he's accurate tree
baby jesus for the prime thank you
very poor time management though that's
the only thing
fast move now ludwig down under two
minutes
this game is crazy guys i mean look at
how far they've come
they were both complete beginners this
is like a this is like a 1600 level game
he play oh and ludwig sees that too and
he takes the rook good now just get your
queen back charlie now there's a
perpetual check here
oh my god he's got rook h6 though
okay he won't see that that would yeah
queen d1 come on charlie get your queen
back attack f3
100 million times i told him to do that
okay but now rook d5 is a rook lifts
then charlie could give a check he wants
rookie three
if ludwig sees rook d5 he's earned the
victory
if vladimir okay king king up rookie
three come on charlie rookie three get
rid of the queen
get rid of the queen come on come on get
rid of the queen see it
see it what do i do first
see ya charlie rookie three get rid of
the queen
kick the queen move come on
oh my god okay but now rook d5
oh okay now they're both panicking queen
c2 charlie
something b4 don't blunter your queen
queen c2 good good good good excellent
move queen e4
45 seconds though oh my god
now ludwig taking a long time this is
amazing this is an incredible high-level
game
okay he has to play a couple of moves
fast ludwig not used to playing bullet
i'm not balding i'm actually incredibly
incredibly proud
of the level that they are both
displaying
and now ludwig is just frozen this is
good he's only okay 96 move the rook to
e3 down e3 attack the queen
rook f7 i don't like that move he he
just he never considers retreating moves
ever
and that's an issue
he he just i as many times as i tell him
to consider retreating moves kick away
your opponent's strongest piece it flies
out the window and time pressure g4 is
not great
from ludwig and queen h7 look at that
though oh rook c8 the queen h5 come on
take the pawn free pawn free pawn free
pawn
take the pawn caroline take the damp on
take the pun move
yeah he's just frozen
he says yes he does it but ludwig now
playing fast move the rook rook g7 come
on
yeah but yes yes amazing play this is
like two professional bullet players
it's unbelievable
now take the pawn but bloody we can go
if i take it with the queen well he see
taking over the queen
how does ludwig find 96 jesus taking him
with he does it
oh my god
holy smokes this game is next level
how is he how are they about finding all
these moves now charlie's winning but
he's low on time
okay but neither of them has time 500
bits
he's traded this is good for charlie now
it's easy to play now black white is
winning but
it's anybody's game i mean this is just
anybody's game
whoever blunders first come on charlie
move the rook yes rook h4s find rook g8
king h2
that's the that's good just don't
blunder the fork on f3
and h1 is even better very good
okay now the clock is even not rogue g1
spin the knight
pin the knight it's easy yes
he gave himself a pin
yes now will he will he be able to win
this
holy smokes this is amazing it's oh it's
not over i mean it's anybody's game here
but now he's got to see f4 knight f3
will liberate from the pin when the rook
knight f3 is
okay this is still anybody's game now
he's up on the clock
f4 i think he'll find out four he's up
on the clock this is looking good if
knight f3 though take the rook don't
pre-move
take the rook charlie take the rook
ludwig found knight f3 that's the right
idea
that's amazing king g1 getting the king
involved good king
whatever king f1 just don't blend with
the fork charlie now he's playing fast
91 man i'm mixing everything here
ludwig defending like magnus okay just
defend the pawn
now he's going to oh rook fade is even
better brooke
just move the king move the king or take
that you can also take it and win the
pawn end game
i didn't expect an end game
king g4 no blunders this one come on
f3 that's fine but these things blood
would bring the king
in he knows end games okay good take the
pawn yes simplify good
king e4 go after them this is like
magnus carlsen literally is playing this
game no no no
don't rush yes king f4 good gang e5 get
up there
who is this guy oh my god
no but don't stale me come on don't say
king d7 charlie come on
don't stalemate him don't stalemate him
he needs six now he's got a minute 42.
slow down
charlie slow down d5 d5
push push his wins def no no what are
you doing
d5 push the passer come on push the
passer
i mean this is so easy push the passer
push it d5 d6
yes
yes d6 you got this he's gonna
i think he's got it in the bag d7 just
yes and queen queen
queen promote
what what hi why this promote the pawn
promote it queen second queen make the
queen yes
oh my god this is amazing queen g5 mate
charlie
queen she five mate that's fine it would
have been stalemate though
didn't have pawns captioning not
and now he's got available get a second
one though
and they're off ludwig with the white
pieces in game two here they go
e4 c5 okay here come the okay c3 c3
sicilian
okay charlie needs to think he's
responded instantly
i don't know what he why he's rushing no
no no that's not the way you want to do
it now ludwig's going to go d5
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh my god this
is already a disaster
no we didn't look at this but he needed
to take a second
just go back to b8 here i don't remember
yeah they prepared they prepared for
for that yeah
he needed to take a little bit longer
now he's starting to think knight b8
just go back and
and i think yeah crazy prep
he didn't look at what he did i mean
okay but now i have four wins oh that
one's a knight
oh no this is just a disaster in the
opening still though
i think you can recover no i see the
problem yep and that's a night here
i mean you just played way too fast
there in the opening
yeah see-through sicilian is a good
choice i should have i should have
thought of that
yeah we went through that yeah we did go
through that
okay bishop g7 good take the pawn for
the piece i think he can recover from
this
i think he can recover from this we've
talked about it
yeah i mean he never played this i i
should have i should have i should have
uh predicted this but
i mean i'm i'm a human being so okay d6
and that f6 is actually not that bad for
black actually
i told him to play d5 yeah we talked
about it previously but we could have
reviewed it thank you rough patrick
this is fine d6 and knight f6 he can
play
d6 and knight f6
yeah he just auto he auto play this but
this is actually pawn for a piece let's
not despair and
ludwig has to play really well to win
this game thank you vertigo sound for
the tier one
ludwig has to play well to win this game
i think he's i think he's going to be i
think he's going to be fine
he can still win i i have beaten other
gm's down a piece like this
i've shown it before he had taken a
little bit longer he would have realized
that he can't just make the same moves
against every opening that's that's
a rookie mistake it's very far from over
ludwig was down a piece he can do this
and he's
he has a pawn bishop d7
yeah bishop d7 now don't move your king
though he's got to realize that trading
is okay
he's already looking to simplify bishop
d7
yeah i mean that's why i do the speeder
and i talk about openings in the speed
run
i think i should d7 come on it should be
seven there's nothing to think about
here
if he moves his king then it's over i
think
i don't know what he's thinking about
yeah but he doesn't have to trade
trade everything but trading a single
piece is fine
he wants to castle no no no no go bishop
b7
he's in check
hovering over the bishop yeah it should
be seven
he's hesitating okay
now a lot of weight lot make my blunder
as queen ludwig might blunder a screen
like this
thanks bishop d7 yes good good good this
is fine if queen a4 blunders his queen
now i can see ludwig do
man big reads
no no no no no and i knew he would miss
it oh my god
how can you miss that no
that's horrible
oh my god i can't believe he missed that
that was the match
how do you miss that how does he miss it
oh my god that was the most basic tactic
ever
take the bishop take the queen that's
what happens when you don't do puzzles
honestly
that's what happens when you don't do
puzzles that's exactly what happens when
you when you don't do puzzles
even though i told him a million times
to do them
yeah that's heartbreaking and now he's
going to lose probably although
this is not over i mean ludwig has to
demonstrate some knowledge here
yeah unbelievable that was a chance of
the match right there
it was a gift doesn't listen and
doesn't check for the stuff i tell them
to check in certain positions
rook c8 get the rook in
yeah this is unbelievable but but um
easy easy winning the queen bishop c3
and queen a4 is resigned
i cannot believe he missed that that is
like a 500 level tactic now i can keep
my bishop on this
okay rook c8 i mean you can still
recover but
yeah this is heartbreaking
[Music]
i'm not mad it's just disappointing
but um it is what it is okay he's got
he's got a recovery rook c8
okay but he's got to see it it's not
exciting it's just not acceptable to
miss that
97 okay that's fine
yeah well i'm disappointed i don't know
if you guys can blame me for that
are you not
i don't know which one would have been
better going this way coming around i
feel like this is better because
i think we're all disappointed i mean
it's necessary to put a label stupid
label on it like malding i'm just
disappointed that he missed uh winning
the queen of the match
um okay so
rook c8 rook c8
so you're looking to break here because
that's not gonna work
yeah i got a shout out yeah i mean
i appreciate it but yeah now he's
watering is playing faster rook ca now i
mean he's
this is still not easy to win so if he
plays fast i think
ludwig might still blunder i told him
that one might blunder this kind of
stuff too
yeah but anyways uh let's see if you can
recover rook fc8
no i i mean let's just get this to the
open file this isn't doing rook c8 good
okay knight b5 a6 ludwig is not playing
this well ludwig is playing too fast and
he's likely to blunder at this rate
it doesn't matter just go a6 charlie's
got to move though now he's taking too
long again
yeah it's fine i mean i'm not going to
scream at him or anything it's not it's
not just about screaming at people
[Music]
no but he's fine i mean this is actually
not that bad you know knight c5 and
we should have just got a big big big
pressure here
he's got big pressure but ludwig is just
finding all these moves like knight c5
get roxy for you know keep keep keep the
pieces involved
but the thing that that disappoints is
that when you're down a piece
you need to be particularly attentive to
these kinds of tactics
yeah knight c5 but now he's he's wasting
all of his time
on nothing not putting it behind him
and uh and not doing what we talked
about rook c4 knight c5 just make moves
come on knight c5
rooks knight c5 rook c4 come on
i think he has this rook see four
knights he's no but he's not moving
here we go
charlie's chances in the armageddon
would be good but first i think he can
still win this game if he just moves
if he just makes a move rather than
losing on time in this position
i have enough time to really think this
through
i just don't know what the [ __ ] to play
what is that five that's a horrible move
rook c4 come on no this is e5
what on passant
no he's collapsed completely rook c4
come on
no that's this just it's just not i mean
[Music]
yeah i i can't believe he's freezing
like this though knight e5
trading nights okay it doesn't ruin
his chances necessarily but you know
it's knight c5 would have been better
yeah this is um
you just don't get a chance like this
every day okay
don't want the bishop or the pawn to
take
but he's he's already in the
championship yeah yeah no he's fine
this is not not over yeah bishop takes
e5 but how is he taking so long on
simple recapture
what yeah now he takes it up you know i
mean he's
psychologically completely collapsed you
can just tell rook d5
now rook c2 though but it still
is a recoverable situation
but it's just a weird move rook c2 is
still
is still there's still some chances i
don't see anywhere he needs a blunder
like it is the only thing that's going
to save him is a one move blunder
yes good okay
one good move in this game
i mean i don't know what people expect
my reaction to be so honestly
okay
yeah ludwig is just playing this like a
like a professional
okay rook fc8 double the rooks
e6 is decent possible
okay now rook d ludwig is playing this
rook d8 bishop a3 is unbelievable if he
finds this
bishop a3 would be crazy
rodwig is playing well f5 would be a
nice move though let me tell you
f5 would put him under some serious
pressure
rook e2 okay so he's going now but if
ludwig finds the right moves he's
winning bishop a three d7 or c1
compliment ludwig zoe blunders now
ludwig might be fixated on defending the
pawn though this is a very hard actually
move to play
excuse me
g5 f6 though f6 and take the pawn
second pawn for the piece f6 is fine i
mean he can do this
there we go
thank you uh bonnie
okay
yes people want me well i mean some
people want me to be happy when charlie
misses an opportunity to win a queen and
win the match
okay take the pawn now take the pawn and
then bring your king up to support the
rook
not over yet
[Music]
good he can win the armageddon too okay
ludwig pushes it
g5 here is good
it's not over yes yeah josh yes it is
bishop f2 but should b6 though
oh no ludwig's oh he sees rook c8 king
f7 king e7 only try
king f7 king e7 is the only try
hmm
i can't i'm i'm i can't believe you
found rook c8
bishop ffa bishop b7 is fine just he's
got to defend the rook
tunnel visioned a little hard on the
left side of the board i didn't see this
you'll see it i think he'll find it of
course charlie is a trans
but he's got a
yeah he's this is not looking good
he's holding the king being that fate is
fine too ludwig should be 1500 for sure
yeah
a lot of it he's not 1100
yeah i just i cannot cannot believe he
missed bishop c3 it's just it doesn't
add up
[Music]
it doesn't add up king f7 finds this
kudos
for that 1500s don't blunder their queen
um what universe are you occupying
okay wow bishop g5 come on king e7 now
win the pun bishop g5 is crazy
oh no yeah he took that oh i didn't even
see the [ __ ] fork
oh god yeah ludwig's seeing absolutely
everything
okay that was the last chance that now
it's over i mean rook d7
forced him to okay bishop h6 would rook
c8
ludwig did his puzzles and charlie
didn't that's that's the difference in
this game
clearly ludwig did his tactics
okay take the pawn you got to take the
pun
hope for the only thing that can save
him is a fork ludwig might miss a four
bishop fork
that's the only thing that can save him
here we're rookie focal distance thanks
for the prime or a stalemate
ludwig is playing like amazing here
yes there should be three h6
okay i mean he's playing well now but
it's too late
king d4
back to c6 don't resign you got to keep
playing
anything can happen
he beat ludwig in the previous arm again
a lot of people won't remember this
yeah rookie seven playing this like a
pro
you can see too maybe ludwig takes the
bishop or something that loses
tough tough tough tough
okay no you you gotta play till mate
gotta test him
bishop before uh ludwig is knows
everything here
yeah he's trying but it's not going to
happen a lot of it gets way too long
yeah he's playing out of his mind
perfect moves
i'm gonna go for a draw okay armageddon
gotta prepare for armageddon
actually that's this is the wrong way
for a draw
[Music]
one second
okay there's no stalemate one second
get your king to a three hope for
stillmate
ludwig like not finding the mate it's
funny
all right guys relax
there now we found it that time
yeah that was tough tough
96.8 yeah well i mean other than that
blunder he played very well let's go
though armageddon
you got this and golden try there we go
c3 i just told him what to play but he
doesn't do it
um but i guess he disabled his messages
and d5 okay so
now he does it nice nice he does he does
what i told him to do
but i told him to play d5 immediately
overlord thank you for the prime
he analyzed it and now he's got this
bishop g4 come on charlie
bishop g4 or just develop your pieces
doesn't matter
oh but he's taking too long already
knight f6 or bishop g4
he's got to move faster already
i i mean he's got to move move
oh my god does he realize he has four
minutes
i i this is un unfathomable
yes bishop g4 e6 come on any anything
move
oh my god e6 just anything knight f6
develop your pieces charlie there we go
he the problem here is that there's no
increment and now ludwig thinking
this is theory e6 bishop e7 come on e6
bishop e7 move
[Music]
let's get one okay i like it i like that
move that's good
that i mean it's not great but it's good
e6 but ludwig knows exactly what to do
and he how long did he spend preparing
for this opening
e6 come on
he's six he has to play fast here cd
okay i don't like no that's not a good
move because now he gives him knight c3
but still e6 is fine for black
the gila mellick and typical maniac he's
got to get his bishop out though
maybe e5 also come on e6 c6 queen h5
e6 come on move move move oh my god this
is just so slow
oh my god i can't i cannot understand
how you play so slow when we get in the
game
yeah e6066 i mean this is just such an
elementary move
oh i'm already taking too much time
whoops
let's move the queen down okay i mean i
guess that's okay but still e6
ludwig is just so confident i forgot
this was five minutes
e6 e6 yes good now move your king out
out of the way i would say
a ludwig is playing with gm that's for
sure but
um he's going to give him a chance
he knows he's taking too much time but
he doesn't want to he there's only two
modes for charlotte it's either
pre-moves or like taking an hour on
every move
all right okay
so now he's sped up okay a4 is does not
does not do anything at all bishop b6
you can also win a pawn here
he forgot it was five minutes okay h5
now they're both attacking this is gonna
get fun
how do you forget it was five minutes
the clock is on the screen
well that's why they shouldn't do arm
again they should just do a damn blitz
match
um armageddon at this level is it is
what it is but
i would have preferred a blitz match
he's gonna speed up and ludwig now
slowing down this is good now
the difference has been shrunk
okay it should be five a6 good get it
get it out of there
that's not a good move from ludwig
oh yeah let's okay queen c6 but rook c1
he's got to move his king move
move your king if rook c1 move your damn
king
or the queen actually but if rook c1 he
has to move
okay b4 no no don't take the knight e5
is a um
b5 though okay this is interesting
this heats up now he's making ludwig
think
no armageddon is a terrible king b8
charlie king b8 no and he blunders his
queen he doesn't ask himself what the
point is of the move
what is bishop before and that knight
moves back and that's a queen
but still not over he's gonna get a rook
for that queen
oh my god how does he find knight a2 i
mean that's just crazy
yep that's uh not good okay but bishop
mack oh
c5 would be a nice move bishop c5 is a
good move rook c5 queen c5 whoops
bishop c5
no no no he blunders everything now he
blunders the bishop what is that
oh my god this is just this this is
horrible
yeah it's heartbreaking
yep well he couldn't he couldn't put it
behind him
ludwig played insane
yeah congrats to ludwig you're in that
um he's cert you definitely earned that
one
now it's over thanks pegasus for the sub
knight a6 is made in the game i didn't
see the pin
i was playing too fast ludwig was
focused he put it behind him charlie
didn't that's the difference
man puzzles is also the difference that
gives him a free fork
charlie got a nice position
yeah but rain is ridiculous yeah
he's got to do puzzles well i can only
tell him so many times
he's he decides what he does with this
time
okay g8 no it's over
he doesn't have a jp if he had more time
maybe but
rain is like 1600 i mean yeah
i think i had him pretty well prepared
you know i think we did everything we
could
he's still in the winner's bracket yeah
still i mean the match itself is
disappointing
rain might be worse than ludwig though
yeah knight c6 point a7 i mean he played
very well
yeah congrats to ludwig
that was yeah heartbreaking but it is
what it is
good game
sorry well i got blasted on that one
yeah that pin i didn't notice it
yeah that was the golden opportunity
that was the one chance he missed and
you could just tell
that how much that shifted after he
missed he missed bishop c3
it's not a disaster it's not the end of
the world everybody's gonna
a lot of people are gonna be very toxic
but it's just
the reality ludwig played better i mean
he was the better player better player
wins in a match
and um charlie played out of his mind
the first game
but um he he buckled and he didn't take
enough time
he didn't play confidently enough and in
this game
um i can't make the moves for him i i
hope you guys realize that
gangba move the king away he's better in
this position not asking yourself
not asking himself what the what the
threat is at all
um it's crazy how confident ludwig is
god son of a that's um
that's real lots of positives he's gone
very far but that's the consequences of
not doing
puzzles regularly but we clearly did
tactics regularly charlie didn't that
shows i shouldn't that's the ultimate
difference game i can't believe they
didn't see that
but obviously he's okay i'm proud of him
he did amazing
and uh it's hard for me to to be happy
but
we got to put things in perspective